Sabasachi Sangupta.
Just nod.
Just nod. Sabiasachi Sangupta.
[Applause]
Thank you, contest chair.
>> You're welcome.
>> I love you so so much.
[Music]
I was talking to the stage.
Uh if you're wondering, you should know
what this stage does to us. This is that
one safe space where we can be creative,
weird, wacky, right?
Give me a little hoohoo if you love the
stage.
I knew that. Because when we are up
here, nothing else in this world matters
except this stage, our craft, and our
audience.
But do we often take this performer
energy into our day-to-day lives? Or we
think the world will judge us, label us,
maybe even laugh at us.
Contest year, Toast Masters and my
performers in this room and all over the
world. For me, finding this stage was
not easy because I grew up in India
where my dad told me I have three career
options
to be a doctor, engineer or be a
disappointment.
But disappointment had its own
hierarchy. Like if I'm in a corporate
job, I am least disappointment. But I
wanted to climb the Mount Everest of
disappointment.
I wanted to be a Bollywood actor.
>> You know Bollywood actor, right? Fix the
balpad the dog. Fix the balpad the dog.
That kind.
But I never had the courage to tell my
father because if I did, just like any
other Indian dad, he would say actor,
somebody is going to get a beating.
So I knew the dream to be an actor was
too far. But life like a Bollywood movie
had its twists and turns and I ended up
in a city called Amsterdam.
And one day while I was attending a
boring finance lecture, I thought what
if I gave myself this chance to be an
actor. Next day I skipped class and I
went for an audition of a play Romeo and
Juliet.
I wanted to be conservative so I went
for the role of Romeo.
The director looked at me and said, "You
want to be a Romeo?" You know why?
Because there were 20 other actors,
tall, chisel jaw, and enthusiastic. And
there was me, enthusiastic.
You want to be an actor? Okay, Mr.
Bollywood, show me how would you propose
to your Juliet?
Showtime.
I looked at Juliet and said, "Oh Juliet,
oh Juliet, you are the love of my life.
Your eyes are as pretty as river Ganga.
Your figure is as perfect as the Taj
Mahal.
Your breath is as fresh as Indian
curry."
Tell me, Juliet, tell me, will you be
mine? If your answer is yes, just nod.
But if your answer is no, just nod
and I'll understand. Cut, cut, cut. Oh
my god, you're the best actor. You
deserve an Oscar.
I believed him
for 5 seconds.
And then I saw everyone laughing.
Then I knew my dream to be an actor was
definitely dead. I can never be a
performer. So I did what anybody with a
broken dream in the city of Amsterdam
would do. Take up a job in finance.
Now finance professionals are really
fun. They are curious. They are
energetic, open to new ideas.
You know, they only believe in data and
numbers. And I'm sure when they sleep at
night, they sleep with a spreadsheet on.
[Applause]
And there I was crunching numbers,
making Excel sheets, wearing blue and
black suits to fit in.
and one day and also attending town
halls, finance town halls that were as
interesting as the Toastmasters annual
general meetings,
not the one from yesterday, from past
years.
And one day we had to do a presentation
within 24 hours notice and everybody
panicked. Nobody knew what to do.
Something in me woke up the performer. I
went to my manager and said, "Can I do
the presentation?
Are you sure, Sabi?
That was a yes, by the way. Use the
existing slides.
That was a no. By the way,
I threw away those data heavy slides. I
put on my red suit and I used a story
that had opening connection, laughter.
And guess what? I saw my colleagues
laugh for the first time. Agree. This
never happens in finance.
After the presentation, my manager came
to me and said, "Dude, you should be the
new CEO
promotion. No, chief entertainment
officer.
You do this so well. You should do more
often. You should teach us."
These guys liked my performance. Like I
thought to fit in finance, I need to be
one of them, those blue suits. And that
day, I unleashed the performer in me.
And people liked me. People like my
performance. And that's when it hit me.
My friends, I do not need a movie set to
live my dream. I can be a performer even
in a boardroom with a clicker and a
projector. A clicker and a projector.
My dear performers in the room, too
often we hold our energy, we hold our
ideas because we think it's not
appropriate for the room. My dear
performers, let's not do that. Let's
unleash that ideas. Let's unleash the
energy. Yes, some days you will be
trolled. Some days you'll be rejected.
Some days you'll be made fun of. But
trust me, some days you'll light up a
room. Someday you'll make someone's day.
And who knows, someday you may even
change someone's life. So my dear
performers, if life asks you, wherever
you are, whichever stage you want to be
on, ask you, are you ready? Just put on
your red suit or put on your red dress.
Step on this stage. Smile and just
>> just nod. Contest here.
[Music]